the freshly retired Pro Bowl all-pro
offensive lineman of your defending NFC
champion San Francisco 49ers Joe Staley
calling into the program how are you Joe
I'm fine so are you all ready overeating
I mean how quickly does somebody go from
playing to retiring basically in the NFL
the opposite I'm pretty quickly getting
into the weight loss
what do you mean realm so you going oh
man you go in the other direction you
going Joe Thomas are you going with Joe
Thomas on me right now
yeah I think every offensive lineman's
dream as they're playing football and
you start playing for a long time it's
just like how much you miss being able
to be at a healthy normal weight and
trying to lose pounds and I'm right now
on that weight-loss journey
so I am eating right now I'm just using
into peloton right now so really
everybody is probably right now so
what's your peloton name in case
somebody goes in the room and and they
see what your what your name is
I am chip Jay I know chip seven for j/s
okay and that is a chip for the
Chippewas for my Central Michigan site I
wanted to make a name that was
inconspicuous I don't want people to
yeah but now I'm told everybody so so I
mean this you know they can write me on
there so if they see to what what's your
peloton name again chip what is it
chip yeah seven for Jay okay so chip for
Chippewa 74 your uniform name and Jay is
for joe staley oh there it is that's me
we just cracked the code crack the code
I've had it for about I don't know 30
days now okay very good
on the bike why did you decide to to
hang him up Joe you know this was a time
for me and I get this isn't for me in
the family you know I was this last year
it was pretty documented you know I miss
the most games I had missed my own
career last year with a broken leg and
the the finger book
and then I had this thing in my neck
that I was kind of dealing with toward
the end of the year and it kind of
gradually got worse and worse and then
once I know the Super Bowl was happening
and kind of came to a head during that
game and then so I realized I was gonna
have to talk to a lot of doctors after
the season was done and then once I did
got a bunch of different opinions and
you know it wasn't really favorable so
you know I kind of just weighed
everything and decided that the time was
now but at the deadline of the you know
the giraffe to make a final decision
that was really important to me today
the Niners were in a good position to
kind of move forward and that was going
to be screwing them over anything with
my decision so really excited at their
landtran yeah mine was transitioning I
know and that's I guess Michael Mike my
question to you is Wendy how much
heads-up did you give the 49ers so they
could get in that in the hunt for for
Trent Williams yes I was and they knew
everything was going on and I was
talking to doctors and you know they
were involved in that home care process
and everything but as far as like an
actual 100 percent decisions visitors
this is what's going to happen you know
I told John and Kyle basically the week
before the draft I was like okay I'll
have a decision for you 100% then so I
think they were making contingency plans
I don't speak for them but I knew that
they were probably doing feelers out
there and stuff and getting stuff
rolling on that front and then once I
told them they kind of move forward and
get the deal done joe staley right here
on the Rich Eisen show fresh off his
retirement from the National Football
League so the guys you played with who
do you think of from your career that
you think stands out Joe I mean there's
so many that I was able to play with and
memories but me and the guys I always
come back to thinking about just friend
Gore number one in my list just because
of the impact that you know I think he
knows now because I made a point of
telling him over the years about how
much of an impact he had in my career
just watching him when I was coming in
as a rookie he was fresh off of 1,600
yards rushing season and he was the man
at the franchise and just seeing the
that you work every single day this kind
of like set the example of what a pro
athlete an NFL player is and how did you
got an act and behave to to make what
you want to make out of your career and
so you had a huge impact on then we
became you know really close friends and
you know still still the same way today
you know getting to practice against
Justin Smith every day this made me such
a better player you know him in Alden at
the same time you know we were kind of
as I was kind of entering my prime of my
career there and being able to go
against those guys every single day in
practice just made me so much better and
then just you know but different players
that you just get to me over the years
you know and competing against and you
know big moments and you know also just
being a little pro bowl and see all the
guys that you just looked up to your
entire life and meeting them and being
around their families there's a ton of
great memories well I think Frank Gore
is a Hall of Famer Joe I don't think
there's any question yeah you didn't
even stay right there I mean what do you
mean would hit what he taught you I mean
cuz again there's a lot of people who
think Frank isn't that impactful because
he's just been around for so long that's
his most impactful thing that he's done
as a career in his careers that he just
did his longevity I'd love to give you
the floor and what I what that means to
you I think you know I think part of
that is because of Frank's personality
you know I think Frank is never going to
be a guy that's gonna you know puff his
own chest out and give himself publicity
he's a guy that just kind of goes to
work every single day and that is part
of it you know getting your name out
there and being a guy that people talk
about all the time and he's on the right
under the radar guy you know I think
just his longevity I think that's not
something to be held against him I think
that's something to be celebrated
because at that position it is
incredibly hard to be year in and year
out consistent and I think that was what
I learn from the most remembers like
what it takes to be a consistent
football player not to someone that has
two three good years but to be a whole
you know Hall of Fame player your whole
entire career you have to work a certain
way and seeing him be on the field
an hour before practice started
you know going through an intense
workout every single day whether it's
getting ready for a playoff game or if
it wasn't you know the middle of May you
know he took everything all day super
serious he made a point of learning
every single aspect that were offensive
we were running you know not just what
he was doing with his responsibilities
were but you know how was the guard
attacking this three technique you know
what's the what's the center's calls on
his past protections I mean he left no
stone unturned and I think that was you
know there's something that stuck with
me forever is that it's not just about
what you're doing it's about what the
whole entire team doing and you know how
can we get better than that that's that
and before I let you go Joe tell me a
good Jimmy G story about why you think
he's the man for the future here you
know so much conversation about the
postseason and how much running was done
on obviously how successful that was and
it was done because Jimmy G wasn't as
effective throwing it that was at least
a narrative and certainly the Super Bowl
where there was a play that to be made
potentially towards the end of the game
that was a possible game-winner
so his effectiveness is a front and
center for a lot of conversation I'd
love to give you the floor here
yeah Jimmy's been nothing but
unbelievable since the day he's got in
there I mean you worked incredibly hard
to learn the entire offense you know
when he was put in a position where he
was kind of looked at as like hey you're
gonna be the savior of a franchise right
now because you know we need you to step
in and you know he came in one of his
five games and then the season we had
last year was an unbelievable ride it
was a huge part of the reason why we
were in the position we were on why we
got to push down by I mean completely
won multiple games during that regular
season for us just by his own you know
arm and you know the play making ability
as far as the playoff game goes I mean
this is what we felt like going into the
games was you know we were in attack
those especially the patcher gaming
those guys off the edge you know Jesus
give him an opportunity we're gonna
throw the ball 30 40 times in the game
you know it's really hard to you know
kind of hold up the entire course of the
game so he felt the best plan of attack
and was working you know I think it's
you going with a plan of attack in your
chest I would really do that but it was
working him you're you were gaining
explosive plays left and right and so
you know was in a position where we had
to control the clock and squeak out 20
21 points again we were able to score 10
points and his little guys to the Super
Bowl and then you know the Super Bowl I
think you know Jimmy would like to have
some of those plays back we all would
like that some of those places like
that's what happens when you lose the
game you don't look back finally on it
so I know it can be a huge motivating
factor for him our offseason and he's
gonna be really good coming up Joe
thanks for joining what's next for you
other than peloton riding and hanging
with the family gone running losing
weight and did some during time down
here and during time with the family and
uh hopefully uh you know seeing some
friends come sometimes some time soon so
get a little stir-crazy here at the
house do my part well if you ever want
to talk some ball you want to get in the
paparazzi if that's the method you want
to go for your you know if you want to
go full Joe Thomas just to give me a
call and I'd love to have you on here
and talks and bow at anytime I'm always
trying to catch though Thomas man he's
been that guy my whole entire career at
trying to be I'm always like one step
behind them so you know hopefully I can
gain him on the weight loss and then I
can try to you know figure out how he so
get everything if every single thing
you know okay I think what is he is he
badge 73 JT on pellet on it so Diaz take
care yourself Jose Jose Daly will chat
with you soon all right thank you yeah
that's Joe stealing fresh retiree hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here